this morning Murray Carter and the
secrets of bladesmithing Carter spent
nearly two decades in Japan before
bringing Eastern techniques West today
he's one of the few Americans who make
custom-made knives full time inside his
shop in Idaho Carter's kitchen knives
are both works of art and exceptional
tools as we got to see and Forge
firsthand
good
the knife has to fit your hand it has to
become a natural extension of your body
[Music]
you have a thought in your mind of what
you want to cut that thought has to
travel down through your arm through
your wrist through your fingers through
the handle of the knife into the blade
and down to The Cutting Edge and
anything that interrupts that flow is
going to work against you
in West Central Idaho nestled between
two mountains the small town of council
is home to a workshop where Murray
Carter lives life on the edge I was
curious at from a young age you know why
do some knives cut very well and and
others don't and that for me that
metallurgical riddle as it were really
intrigued me
Carter had a troubled childhood growing
up in Canada so as a teenager he
traveled to Japan to study martial arts
he also found someone to teach him
Japanese knife making and after a long
period of study became the 17th
generation yoshimoto bladesmith
following 18 years overseas Carter moved
to the U.S and began selling custom-made
knives for kitchen use
some of which can run into the thousands
of dollars for somebody who says like I
can go on Amazon and buy like a knife
for 30 or 40 bucks whatever a kitchen
knife it cuts great it works great for
me why do I need something that costs 10
times that does it though does it cut
great what I'm hoping here today is
we're going to go through the process of
making a knife and after a day of making
a knife and then we finally have the
finished product in hand you know the
calculation is is that that is going to
be a transformational experience for you
foreign
[Music]
never done it before giving birth to a
knife here how hot is it inside there in
Fahrenheit 5 000 something degrees
[Music]
Carter uses Japanese White Steel which
is low in impurities like phosphorus and
sulfur but high in carbon which
increases strength
it's a tradition that comes from forging
samurai swords as early as the 8th
century
and then we just put it in there
wow so what does it do in there it's
annealing it's cooling slowly these
ashes are insulating it so that it can
cool more slowly than if it was just in
the air annealing which softens the
metal is the first of three crucial
steps that turn a simple piece of Steel
into a high performance blade now with
your fingers feel how smooth that is
oh my gosh yeah wow it's like a baby's
bottom
so now what we need to do is refine the
shape okay drill holes stamp your name
on here and get it ready to heat you get
it ready to quench okay
[Music]
[Applause]
hold on good and tight to the blade let
the drill do the work before it could be
finished off
G our new custom blade needed a nice
Personal Touch I have to do the rest
okay yeah do at least one more all right
well I'll tell you what here I'll hold
it you give it a good well I don't want
to hit you that's okay don't hit me
don't don't hit me
nice
that looks awesome wow that's holding my
breath on that one it's awesome
quenching which cools the blade quickly
and tempering which reheats it to
increase its toughness are the last
steps before attaching the handle
finally we put this metallurgical
Masterpiece to the test
oh man feel that
wow
that's beautiful
okay am I slicing away or anything you
want to cut
oh
come on come on
wow
you can hold this magazine kind of hold
it taut like that and see if you can cut
the corner off
and I'm going to be honored if you would
take that knife home with you and use it
every day the honor is mine thank you
very much
[Music]
on the wall behind us is an ancient
proverb simply put it says that taking
action and failing is better than taking
no action at all
that philosophy is not all Carter
brought back from Japan
where he arrived as a boy craving
Direction
and left a master of his craft
[Music]
what'd you say I said I said I had a you
know tough childhood but I'm really
content now as an established placement
I guess contentment is what you were
looking for all along
a sense of purpose yeah fulfillment
peace peace in my heart do you have that
now I sure do
[Music]
one of the most memorable experiences
I've ever been a part of it looked like
it I mean just being able to see it from
beginning to end beautiful story his
yeah and that both of them truly I mean
we were watching like this yeah we were
like rap by the process of making this
blade it's fascinating I mean I've
always been fascinated about it but I've
never seen it up close and I just love
the piece that he talks about that he's
found yes through this really beautiful